bismillah al hamdulillah assalamu
alaykum that's the greeting of all the
messengers and the last and final
messenger greeted his followers Jesus
greeted his followers Moses Abraham with
this greeting of peace and we're wishing
you that same greeting peace be unto you
thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Dean show to check out
our show times visit the Dean show calm
we're here every week trying to help you
understand Islam and Muslims and today
we're going to be talking about Dawa
what does it mean is it enough
obligation is it something you know I
just do for fun is it something that you
know what we just leave for the guys
with the bigger beards or the guys who
have memorized more Koran or the people
who are the scholars that we just leave
it for them or is this something for
everybody what are the do's and don'ts
of it we want to get you motivated so
you know that this is something
wonderful this is something that all the
messages of God did and you're losing
out if you're not doing it and also for
our brothers in humanity the non-muslims
our life is an open book we don't have
no secret meetings that you aren't
inviting to you're invited to this too
are we there to try to prostitute eyes
to you are we there to try to just
convert you and force Islam down your
throat are we just trying to give you an
invitation or something i'll give you
peace they'll give you life when we neck
when we come back with our next guests
we're going to be covering this very
very important topic love there's only
one
is his messenger Allah Allah Allah
there's only one word and Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice let's
bring out my brother and your brother el
mekki my little brother please have a
seat have seen you on the DS oh please
peaceful salamo alaikum no mom excited
brother excellent so am I not really
excited rather great you excited let's
do this man because this is something
that's dear to my heart actually no
excited to have you here my pleasure to
be on the big show I'm good how good
luck how was your flight so it was great
yeah everything is hundred percent
hundred I'm the lot you have your own
section on the Dean show so people go
there and see some of the other shows
that we've done I'm but we got break
some ice and we got it you know it's
encouraged that we give gifts but yeah
Oh was ever gifting this is I mean we
thought this would be a great gift the
brothers at half date have you heard a
half date no half date they helped do a
dialogue drive and they have collected
some things for us that we were able to
get a lot more what we call dvds for
doubt you're the dowel machine this is a
whole truckload not a truckload with a
bag load of dvds for dollar oh no you
know and the show is over i'm not giving
this back no you're not those are all
great people must these are the volume
two fantastic yeah so they helped us
well now this is drive together and we
want to give it to you and get this out
this message of peace out to the world
this is the part of that doll where took
DVDs you've got the doctors I could
knock you've got your holy bassoon you
don't let me started their excellent
much I love ya like a fish well yeah
cool excellent so now this is something
that is crucial hour let's get right to
it so little time so much of brain
picking to do is an obligation what does
it mean
let's start with that excellent so let's
start with the meaning because when you
understand the meaning you understand a
lot of other things that come with it
because that were it comes from the
Arabic Ted to all right which means to
invite right so it's an invitation that
was an invitation and you invite people
to something so because when you look at
it and it means invite it can't be a
fight a lot of people think that way is
a fight it's a debate it's as many
debate you have with people you you trap
them into a corner make them
uncomfortable and then that's it then
they become Muslim but that's not how it
works like I'm right you're wrong that's
it and they take it or leave it it is
the kind of a debate but it's not and
it's an invitation and have you ever had
anyone invites you by by grabbing you
putting a fist to your face and saying
you gotta come to my house for dinner no
it doesn't work no one invites like that
scaring people then so for first thing
we'd like to go understand it's an
invitation it's an invitation it can't
be a fight so don't fight with people
and don't try to make people
uncomfortable you gently call them into
a la you want them to be in developing
the mercy of Allah so it yet so you
don't want to make it a fight and you
don't want to send them away from the
religion because of the harshness and
the crudeness and your behavior that's
the first thing that's a definition so
invitation absolutely do we have this
mindset like we have to now convert
people that this is our duty that now we
have to make them see that Allah God
Almighty is one worshiped him alone
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was a
messenger like Jesus the last and final
messenger is this like our obligation to
make their hearts believe this like some
other faiths do absolutely not your
obligation is just to tell people what
the truth is just deliver the message
and allows the deal would even say about
his messenger sallallahu ala moana a
little soda isabella it the only
obligation upon the messenger is to
convey the message that's this job is
not it's not anyone's job to go into
someone's heart and change their heart
your job is to tell people what the
truth is alright as clearly as possible
and it is nice away as possible make it
understandable as possible then you can
remind them again next week a month from
now it's not a problem but the point is
the rest is up to Allah is diligent if
you open the heart to Islam or not you
did your job that's it and you can do
your job again in the
and again with the same person there's
no limit to the number of times you can
cause someone to a lot but that's your
job see you know the problem is that it
when people feel that their job is to
change people's hearts most likely
you'll expect that they'll be
unsuccessful in that and when they're
unsuccessful in that they feel let me
just give up with this day i think is
i'm not good at it yeah that's because
you put the wrong task in front of you
that's not your job just tell them about
it so now you're talking my job is this
as I said before for someone who has
more knowledge someone who's a shake or
a scholar or someone who's memorized the
Quran now say you know what that that's
that's for the big dogs as they say
that's for the people who went to Medina
went to as har went to this school
Islamic academy who is this job for
unfortunately that is the thought that
you know the people anyone with a beard
over 3 inches they give that way I just
well I said and watching but the truth
is there are levels of Dawa right there
are different levels of Dawa and some
levels you need to like first for
example giving a fatwa you know that's
not my job and it's not your job the
mufti gives fat our that's a very high
level right then there are certain
things like you know teaching people in
the Messiah that would be like an imam
or someone well versed enough to teach
and explain al Qaeda or something like
that then there's a very basic level of
Dawa very basic level of forbidden
forbidding anything that's evil and in
joining what's good this basic level
anyone can do it that's basic anyone can
do it so on the basic level it's an
obligation upon every living Muslim
let's hold off and come back on that
point
Dean shows my brother your brother the
down machine I call you the dowel
machine you know what I mean because you
know what a machine keeps going doesn't
it huh doesn't stop keeps going and
working you know we try to take a break
here and there but the idea is we're
going to die and Angel def is coming and
this is a beautiful way to get closer to
this way of life by constantly sharing
it with others and it's helping you also
to increase in your Iman and that's like
that machine i'm talking about you just
will be running many ppl park the car
the machine and they don't turn it out
at all but you keep it going well for
the benefit of the doubt first of all
it's a maybe it not as you described it
but anyway and so basically we're saying
that because look some people argue they
say it not everyone's obligated to give
down and they cite evidence from the
Quran yeah right a large incision over
on with the cumin cumin adona in Allah
let their rise out of you a group of
people calling to Allah you see yes I
clearly says let a group of people call
to Allah so they say that we don't all
have to give della you know if there's a
group if there's an organization or in
his Chicago that gives doua then that
takes the blame off of me so the
scholars explained that a group here is
talking about the the specific things
like many high levels of Dawa that only
certain people could do but then on low
level anyone anyone I'll give you a
simple example that always again suppose
there's a guy very uneducated doesn't
know much about politics history Islam
I'll tell you anything he just prays
five times a day and let's say he has no
skill besides making brooms one day
he'll make brooms the next day who
suffer in the market that is it so no no
level of knowledge whatsoever he makes
brooms any subs in the next day now you
might ask me okay what kind of
obligation what kind of dow is
obligatory upon this guy got no
knowledge there is something you can
always think of something he could do
he's walking to the market he's his two
kids cursing each other up can he tell
them you audit boy don't say that can
you do that he's definitely he can you
tell his children don't lie yes can he
be can he tell the person he's dealing
with in the market that I know I don't
lie or can you give
by saying things like you know I'm going
to give you the honest price and then
when I when I deal with someone in
business I don't swear it by Allah's
name it can he give that were like that
absolutely so you cannot think of a
scenario where anyone in the OMA cannot
do any kind of in joining what's good or
forbidding with Steve oh cool who Allah
along handed alamos pomander let me le
duela muted well I'm cuckoo for
one-handed say Allah is one yes I mean
if you just know this even that you
don't even have it memorized the whole
sewer just cool hoo allah hoo ha say
Allah is one and so you're talking to
people you're delivering that your Lord
is one no that's it and the person said
convey about me even if it's just one
the earth so that so this are we saying
everyone's obligated to give Jim a hot
tubbin explain book no yeah but on a
basic level everyone's obligated to
enjoin what's good and forbid what's
evil which is that one yeah that way
isn't just specific things and I know a
lot of people like to make that way you
know just walking in the street just
handing out pamphlets you know no Jimmy
Hoffa's Dawa teaching in the message
dialog you know telling someone don't do
this do that in joining good forbidding
you all that is Dawa so anyone can do it
now what should the main theme of the
Dow be what is the main thing that
you're trying to get across not to the
people will this dawid this invitation
okay now because like we're using Java
as the general term yeah the scholars
say that your goal is to make people
more knowledgeable or better worshippers
of a loss upon yeah that's your goal you
know so whatever it is that will get
people closer to Allah region or have
more knowledge of a lot or more
knowledge of their religion now if you
want to use now ended in the sense of
talking to to non-muslims or calling
people to Islam inviting people to Islam
then here obviously you would you want
to keep as a specific message and a
clear message that comes through when
you talk because a lot of times when
people give Dawa in that case where
they're talking to someone trying to
tell them about Islam they just throw
random bits of information yet the
person hoping that something will stick
and or something might strike the right
chord and then they'll become Muslim and
that's actually not the right way to do
the right ways to have an idea you want
to take them through a thought process
and explain it clearly but you also need
to find out you know what obstacles they
have what other belief system they
belong to that because that's your
obstacle you remove that you present
them with the oneness of allah so
judging you move from there so it's got
to be systematic and organized a little
bit not just not scattered all over the
place absolutely not so the main thing
should be the would you say the oneness
of Allah yes suppose I'm talking to a
non-muslim then I want to start first of
all I need to know who they are yeah
right if I tell you right now Eddie just
outside the studio there's someone who's
not a Muslim go speak to him you cannot
prepare your entire speech right here
yeah right because you might plan okay
I'm going to go outside I'm going to
shake their hand give them a hug then
you go outside and it's a woman yeah
there goes plan a right so you plan it
based on the individual so what if he's
an atheist you have the Atheist speech
ready for him right maybe someone who
believes in Trinity you have the Trinity
speech ready what if he's someone who is
a Hindu you've got the Hindu speech
ready and what if someone who just has
no religion is as I don't tell me about
Islam then you've got the speech the
permian on Islam prepared so that means
you prepare your talk based on the
individual you don't have a you know I
prepared rehearsed speech and you just
give it to anyone you meet yeah right
and this is what the people need to
understand that the daya because Dawa
there's so many variables that I has to
be malleable has to be flexible you have
to be able to adjust and based on the
situation and there are many situations
you run into when you find you need to
adjust your talk you keep adjusting the
talk and one time I was talking to a man
and he had this child with him he's a
young boy maybe eight nine years old but
it was very important for this father to
show his sunday is that he's a man so
every time I spoke to the father he kept
telling me you're talking to both of us
right he wanted me to look at his son so
now I had to adjust my whole speech I
had to keep looking at him and spending
a lot of time looking at this kid you
know so it's not something that would
have been used to or put in mind before
but I had to know just my speech to
satisfy that so basically have to be
flexible you have to be malleable and
it's to go with whatever is the
situation the
problem the person has you know some
people have different problems this
person will believe everything you say
but I don't like the issue of divorce
and slap or I believe everything say but
there's a specific obstacle that I have
or I'm ready one hundred percent but my
mother is not ready for me deck so then
you have to come up with solutions so
the intention has to be there that look
if we get to talk about baseball
football you talk about everything under
the Sun but you're not talking about the
purpose of life why you've been created
sharing that with the non-muslim
colleagues or the people that you
interact with that's a problem is it
it's a big problem and how do you know
those people aren't going to come on the
day of judgment and use you as an excuse
you know for their misguidance before
their co for they might comment and use
you as an excuse well I knew this man
for 20 years he never spoke to me about
Islam he was my neighbor for 15 years
not once that invite me to it's not the
everyone wants an excuse on the day of
judgment how do you know they won't use
you as an excuse so that's why you got
to go out there and talk to people and
tell them just like it you said you're
talking about baseball for two hours why
not talk about aloe once and it's I mean
it's real simple I mean just when people
get down to the nitty-gritty of life and
you just start to have people to think
why they are here in this life why
they've been created simple things like
that right is this I mean tell us now is
this so we is this effect it's incumbent
on every person who is a Muslim to give
the invitation to this way of life this
is without a doubt no shadow doubt that
this is an obligation well there's some
there's some scholars who say that since
you chose to live in a land that that
where the Muslims are minority then one
of your obligations is to tell people
about Islam tell people but Allah now
you might think not okay well someone
might argue now that not everyone is
able to do that I mean it takes you have
to have your you know now your verses
and be ready and be eloquent would be
brave enough to walk up to people the
mercy of Allah so again is that he puts
so many avenues through which you can do
something he didn't ask every single one
of us to go stand in the street corner
and just call random strangers and just
let him have it and know you could do it
through the internet you could do it
through I'm you know articles you could
do it through passing out material and
not talking to anybody real simple you
can mail people material mail
to him yes give me an email anything I
mean pamphlet get that message to
anything give them cds whatever it is
given the Dean show yeah there you go
vol 1 and 2 just not from my bag though
yeah we got the ten-minute Shahada okay
well that's mostly for Muslims right you
to learn the techniques that's that's a
great tool there also and the guy who
does it very very handsome mashallah
they can see it right now on the screen
they've seen the cover okay great great
so okay so we know that this is
something that's incumbent it's
something that brings blessings in your
life talk to us about the benefits
people want us know what am I getting
when I do this all right first of like
suppose now I tell you look Eddie who
there is there's this investment
opportunity all right but it's going to
close in one hour look whatever amount
of money you give me right now to invest
in this whatever you put in it's going
to be x seven then it's going to be
multiplied the seven each one of them
will be multiplied by 100 and then the
hundreds could just keep multiplying mhm
now you will do everything to put as
much money as you can with before that
out one hour window closes right you're
gonna borrow your gonna put as much
money spot you won't say here here's ten
bucks yeah let that x 72 70 x 100 each
that's fantastic you can say wait a
minute let me get all the money i can
get hey can i borrow this for me hey Dad
can I borrow a thousand hey can i book
and you put as much money as you can
because the reward is so great yeah you
know Allah subhana Allah multiplies the
reward for the door so much and it and
just the fact that you're giving Dawa
illogical says no Quran woman asano
Poland mean man died in Allah here i'm
gonna soil and ricotta in any real moose
lemme allah is asking and it's a
rhetorical question so he's really
telling us no speech is better than to
do that were to call people to Allah and
to do there were no speeches better no
nothing is better than that let's hold
off on that no speech is better and
we'll be right back on the Dean show
he's an initial talking about that
invitation invitation to peace that
invitation that gives you peace that
invitation to worship the one who
created you serve him along without any
associates that is Islam talk to us now
some of the benefits the wonderful
benefits that a person gets from giving
the invitation to his brothers and
humanity excellent so the last thing we
said that it's the best speech you can
say that's better than this better than
calling people to Allah but
interestingly two things though you
called to a lot it's not about you not
about your ego not about you know
telling people that I'm the Daiya or the
down machine anything like that then and
then also so you're calling but then
which is why I'm in a solid and you do
the good deeds yourself yeah sound like
you call people you know you show them
the lighting you practice what you
preach exactly yeah you practice what
you preach so like if you find other
things like and very interesting how if
you teach someone now how to pray right
every time you pray you get your reward
every time they pray because you taught
them you get reward then if he takes
what you taught them and he teaches 10
other people every time those 10 him and
the 10 pray you get 11 rewards for each
time they pray what's yours then if the
10 go and teach their kids how to pray
it just keeps going on and on and on and
it doesn't diminish anything from the
other person at all now if someone told
you there is a stock where your dollars
multiply like that people would sell
their clothes to to invest as much as
they could into it but then when Allah
tells us this and the president told us
this were like oh that's nice to know
that's great that's great is there any
waste of time if the person doesn't even
you know he turns a blind eye to what
you're saying you know that's what
people think they think that for you to
get reward for da what people need to
convert No yeah the act of you standing
there giving dawah or sitting or
whatever it is giving that you get
reward for that know how they said I'm
the Prophet Noah he gave da for over
nine hundred fifty years he told me he's
not a few people believed you told me he
doesn't get much reward for those 950
years that's amazing he get through it
show us how easy it is give us some
stories examples okay I'll give you one
example and this is something basically
that I mean ever just about all your
listeners in shallow
overly more than ninety-nine point nine
percent of them would qualify you know
could do a higher level than this man
this is a man paralyzed from the neck
down words he can only speak and he sits
at the hospital all day and night he
just lives at the hospital so he's
paralyzed from the neck down words he
can only speak and he brought a hundred
people to Islam basically when a
non-muslim walks by he says you see the
bench bunch of pamphlets on the floor
there sir excuse me could you please
take it but he's paralyzed he's
paralyzed he can only speak can't even
point like I was pointing when I was
saying take a bath you can't even do
that can't do it he just says you see
the path was on the floor there was I
going to read it that should be
encouragement for us all look at that
that's it so there's no way that your
your listeners you know or below that I
mean they're able to at least move type
send the email do something yeah but
like I said again it's from the mercy of
Allah he makes so many avenues through
which you can do dawa ya so if you if
you feel like you know speeches and
going out and speaking and this night is
not your field find an avenue because
there's so many go out and feed the poor
do there's a million and one and then
and then that is brought to you by Islam
great exactly all right yeah you got it
you got to plug the sponsor exactly yeah
yeah excellent tell us now we're almost
out of time and again so much things and
this is just to give people that
motivation that they need to get out
there and do what all the messengers of
God did but there's like some stigma
people be like you know what a lot of
times when you bring up religion because
of some other favs now it's gotten a bad
rap but we know Islam is logical
rational makes sense and usually when
people hear it you know what it just
stimulates something because it's not
blind faith how do we get past some of
these stereotypes this is something I'm
sure you you'll you've experienced
yourself yes to all the people who have
given that in America you know Canada
Australia it will try to take it like
all religions are the same now but if
you ask the dot it's true there most
people think there's a stigma there's an
issue and they might you know you might
meet some aggressive people and don't
want to hear it from you but talk to do
out all around the world it's a great
experience you're out you're talking to
people you put your hands on the
shoulders you love you exchanged phone
numbers you it's a it's not a fight when
we got to da hua university wherever
it's not a fight it's a good day do I
love it they get in a rush and their
mind increases and it's a very nice
extreme I increases rightly it's helping
you to develop boss it's like one day I
said you know if you're watching a
garment with your hand at the end of the
process your hand is clean yeah but you
were trying to watch the garment but
your hand became cleansed in the process
same thing you're calling people to a
less drawing you closer to Allah is it
true that if one person and the Allah
giving you the ability to guide someone
with a lost permission the craters
permission that is better than
everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be gave out
giving Dawa we really felt it we would
never stop giving that one okay for our
non-muslim guests people that can tune
in every week and we're encouraging them
because they're our brothers and
humanity let them be our brothers in
faith what is this call what is this
dowel given the down the call is
basically if you believe in Allah you
believe in a creator that he is the only
one who has no partner no children no
relatives anything like that that he's
one eternal and absolute and that he
sends all the prophets to guide people
to humanity just like he sent Jesus and
Abraham and Moses and all the other
prophets he also sent the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu salem in Arabia 1400
years ago who came with the same basic
messages all the prophets did not
deviate from it and if you believe that
he could have possibly sent the Prophet
Muhammad as one of his prophets then you
already have the ingredients with which
to become a Muslim because to become
Muslim all you have to do is say exactly
just that with your tongue that there is
no God worthy of worship except allah
and that muhammad is his servant and his
messenger that's simple that is and the
reward is the reward is and Jenna
paradise paradise because we're all
going to die that's a reality louder was
not a fantasy that's something that's a
fact everyone's going to die just real
quick a few seconds okay some tools that
they can use for the Muslims you have if
people want some more things that they
can get familiar with you have this
ten-minute Shahada for the Muslims yes
if they want to learn that word
techniques there's a workshop called how
to give
had in 10 minutes you can find that on
YouTube one many many other websites
have it and they have different versions
of it a lot of people have heard that
and they brought someone about a hundred
and some of them about 50 people to
Islam just by listening to to that
workshop it teaches you doubt with
techniques what to say what not to say
how to address all these things are
mentioned in it and inshallah very
beneficial what pathless do you like
those things that you know will address
the common misconceptions of Islam being
associated with terrorism which is
something that Islam condemns the other
false miss concepts Tarot's types that
people have you know the concept of God
the what is Islam there's some beautiful
pamphlets by what who who prints it like
why islam or yeah they have though many
of them whoever has them you know it's
what are some of the pamphlets that you
recommend that what what they we
recommend is that you read each but the
best pamphlet is based on the individual
and the individual yeah so get those
their real nice and colorful and I mean
not just because we did a show can I get
one of those one of your gifts you'll
get it back yeah okay you also I mean
we've gotten the best out there hummed a
lot of people like yourself we're going
to have you in Charlotte vol 3 I mean
you got the DVD for Dawa I mean if
someone has done the work take if it's
the flyers if it's someone else that you
like you serve estes whoever it is if
they put something together use it this
is something that we thought we have
some of the people's stories how they've
come to islam some of the great duas
students and knowledge scholars and this
is something that we encourage all the
MSAs all the dowel organizations the
musjid to get this we want to print more
we give these to the non-muslims for
free for free for free we want our
brothers in humanity to become our
brothers in faith and at least even if
they don't accept a message there's no
coercion coercion in religion it's up to
them they're free choice but at least
they understand us a little bit better
now so this is what we have and with
that said thank you very much okay
allowed the crater road you for being
with us Sophie and that is it for this
episode of the Dean she'll do that
simple task that God Almighty has asked
you to do be the best human being that
you can be you can't do that following
your own desires you have to do it by
the game plan
game plan is God's game plan a lost game
plan and that is to submit your will to
his will Islam and that's how you gain
peace is that simple is that easy and
then share it share with your colleagues
your neighbors everyone around you and
nothing less than paradise is the final
reward I hope you have got to understand
some of the beautiful things that we
have said we'll see you next time here
on the Dean show it salaam alaikum peace
be unto you it's cold it's late
everybody sleeping I arise and ask a lot
of thinking me Omar you see hola you
know all the sins I do I turn to you to
figure my sin tomorrow I'm seen for
slave you're my love alone I'm the one
runs away oh the guide me mr. Langham
more mana Wahine in a fee home this
summer with he was only 150 laughing
lady one
her diet luckily only little babe Aladin
is no more hopping a memo
don't be him when the [ __ ] y'all know
Neffe hanabi summer wedding went alone
Rob nmf all of water has a super hard
again [ __ ] me now